ha muerto esta tarde el expresidente
jeansemina a los 96 años en Shanghai de
leucemia según la prensa china yang es
una de las figuras más relevantes de la
política contemporánea china no solo por
su mandato sino también por los 10 años
posteriores
dentado sobre el que proyectó una
influencia extrema solo el febril
acaparamiento de poder de Pink consiguió
arrinconar a su clan de shanghaique por
primera vez se quedó sin ningún
representante en el comité permanente
del polígono elegido en el reciente
congreso del partido y han subió al
poder tras la matanza de Diana mena en
1989 en sustitución de chao chillán que
había sido purgado por su apoyo a los
estudiantes yang tenía fama de burócrata
y se esperaba que sirviera de puente
entre las diferentes facciones pero hizo
bastante más que eso de su mandato se
recuerda el ingreso de china en la
Organización Mundial del Comercio la
masiva invitación a multinacionales
extranjeras a producir en el país y la
entrada en el partido de empresarios
privados que habían sido perseguidos
durante décadas ya fue un pragmático que
profundizó en las reformas de densalping
consiguió crecimientos económicos
espectaculares de dos dígitos pero fue
un crecimiento a toda Costa que creó
desajustes extremos como desigualdades
sociales o la ruina medioambiental sus
Sucesores tanto hushington como
políticas mucho más sociales han
intentado mitigar todos aquellos
problemas que llevaron al país al borde
del precipicio